Das ist wirklich eine Wahnsinns-Meldung aus
China: Ein Forscher behauptet, die weltweit
ersten genveränderten Babys erschaffen zu
haben!
Man habe das Erbgut von zwei Embryonen gentechnisch
so verändert, dass die beiden Zwillinge resistent
gegen HIV seien.
Bisher liegen noch keine unabhängigen Bewertungen
des Experiments vor, doch Forschungs-Teams
weltweit sind geschockt.
Denn fest steht: Solche Menschenversuche wären
der Super-GAU schlechthin.
Falls sich diese Behauptung aus China bewahrheiten
sollte, hätte das krasse Folgen für die
Ethik und die gesamte Wissenschaftswelt!
Und es hat jetzt schon Konsequenzen für die
beteiligten Wissenschaftler.
Welche?
Jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier
gibt es täglich spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts!
herzlich willkommen!
Konkret geht es um den chinesischen Forscher
He Jiankui von der Southern University of
Science and Technology in Shenzhen.
Er behauptet in einem Interview mit der US-Presseagentur
“Associated Press” (AP) (vom 26.11.18),
dass weltweit die ersten beiden genmanipulierten
Babys geboren worden seien.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler in einem Youtube-Video:
“Zwei wunderschöne kleine chinesische Mädchen
namens Lulu und Nana kamen vor einigen Wochen
weinend und so gesund wie jedes andere Baby
zur Welt”.
Er habe das neue Allzweckwerkzeug der Gentechnik,
das Crispr/Cas9-Verfahren genutzt, um die
Kinder resistent gegen HIV zu machen.
WTF!!!
Kurz noch einmal zur Erklärung der sogenannten
Crispr/Cas9-technologie (kurz Crispr), über
die wir hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
immer mal wieder berichten: Die Methode revolutioniert
gerade die Gentechnik, denn mit ihrer Hilfe
lassen sich ausgewählte Gene einfügen, ausschalten
oder auch umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach.
Es funktioniert quasi so simpel wie ein Schere.
Mit ihr kann die DNA, also das Erbgut ziemlich
effektiv verändert werden.
Bisher gibt es beispielsweise Versuche, Krankheiten
bei einzelnen Personen zu therapieren, doch
in den Keimzellen von Menschen wurde sie bislang
noch nicht angewendet.
Das ist auch extrem gefährlich.
Denn bei dem Verfahren werden auch immer wieder
andere Bereiche des Erbguts verändert, die
eigentlich gar nicht verändert werden sollen.
Das kann dann bedeuten, dass Erbkrankheiten
ausgelöst werden, das die genmanipulierten
Lebewesen leichter Krebs bekommen können
und und und.
Deshalb und aus ethischen Gründen sind Menschenversuche
mit Crispr/Cas9 verboten.
Und die Folgen sind noch weitreichender: Denn
die gentechnischen Veränderungen sollten
nicht nur die nun geborenen Zwillinge selbst
betreffen.
Falls der Plan von He Jiankui wirklich aufgegangen
sein sollte, befinden sich die Veränderungen
in allen Zellen im Körper der Babys - somit
könnten sie diese auch an ihre Nachkommen
weitergegeben.
Konkret soll der Forscher mit Hilfe der Crispr/Cas9-Technologie
quasi eine Art Eingangstor ausgeschaltet haben,
über das das Aids-Virus HIV normalerweise
in die menschlichen Zellen gelangt.
Genauer gesagt geht es um das Gen für den
sogenannten CCR5-Rezeptor, an den sich HI-Viren
für eine Infektion der Zelle anheften.
He Jiankui jedenfalls behauptet, 16 Embryonen
von insgesamt sieben Paaren mit der Crispr/Cas9-Methode
behandelt zu haben.
Die Mütter waren gesund, die Väter mit HIV
infiziert.
Die Embryos wurden per künstlicher Befruchtung
geschaffen.
Elf der behandelten Embryonen wurden dann
wieder in die Frauen eingesetzt, wobei es
letztendlich dann eben zu dieser einen erfolgreichen
Schwangerschaft kam.
Laut dem Interview mit dem chinesischen Forscher
sei der Plan aber nur bei einem der Zwillinge
erfolgreich gewesen: Bei dem anderen wurde
wohl nur eines statt der beiden verantwortlichen
Gene herausgeschnitten, sodass eine Infektion
mit HIV weiter möglich sei.
Jiankuis Angaben zufolge sei die Wahrscheinlichkeit
aber hoch, dass die Erkrankung nicht so aggressiv
verlaufe wie gewöhnlich.
Klar ist jedenfalls: Die Folgen dieser Behandlung
sind komplett unbekannt und die Zukunft der
beiden Kinder somit voll,kommen ungewiss.
Fachleute weltweit sind entsetzt, denn schließlich
weiß man beispielsweise nicht, ob die herausgeschnittenen
Gene vielleicht für andere wichtige Vorgänge
im Körper notwendig sind.
Das Experiment ist zudem bisher nur in einem
chinesischen Register für klinische Tests
eingetragen - mehr aber aber auch nicht.
Zu Behauptung Jiankuis gibt es also noch keine
geprüfte wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichung,
genauso wenig wie eine offizielle Bestätigung
von anderen Behörden.
Und so rätseln Fachleute aus der ganzen Welt,
was wirklich dahinter steckt.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Falls sich diese Behauptung
aus China bewahrheiten sollte, hätte das
Konsequenzen für die gesamte Wissenschaftswelt
und ihre Ethik!
Die Universität, an der He Jiankui arbeitet,
hatte sofort reagiert und mitgeteilt, dass
man nichts von diesem Experiment gewusst habe.
Man sei “schockiert” und weiter heißt
es, dass die entsprechenden Experimente außerhalb
der Universität stattgefunden haben.
Der Wissenschaftler habe damit "ernsthaft
gegen die akademische Ethik und akademische
Normen" verstoßen.
Und auch von anderen chinesischen Kollegen
erntet He Jiankui große Kritik.
Sie befürchten, dass das Ansehen der chinesischen
Forschung damit zerstört wird.
In einem Protestbrief fordern sie die Aufsichtsbehörden
auf, schnell zu handeln.
Zudem schreiben sie: "Direkte Versuche am
Menschen können nur als verrückt beschrieben
werden.
Es ist zwar möglich, dass die Kinder, die
diesmal geboren wurden, für einen bestimmten
Zeitraum gesund sind.
Aber die potenziellen Risiken und Schäden
für die gesamte Menschheit, die durch einen
ungerechtfertigten Einsatz des Verfahrens
in der Zukunft entstehen können, sind unermesslich”.
Und auch die internationale Wissenschaftswelt
ist geschockt.
Dies sei ein Affront gegenüber der Wissenschaft,
die voller Verantwortung zu diesem Thema der
Genmanipulation forscht, heißt es beispielsweise
vom Deutschen Ethikrat.
Der Vorsitzende Peter Dabrock sagt: “Sollte
es sich bewahrheiten, dass ein mithilfe von
Crispr/Cas9 genmanipuliertes Baby erzeugt
worden ist, wäre dies für die Wissenschaft
ein Super-GAU”.
Denn nicht nur in den USA und Europa ist es
derzeit gesetzlich verboten, einen Embryo
gentechnisch zu verändern und diesen dann
einer Frau einsetzen, damit diese schwanger
wird.
Denn die Risiken derartiger Manipulationen
an menschlichem Erbgut sind bisher kaum abschätzbar
sind.
Hinzu kommt ja noch: Solche Veränderungen
würden an nachfolgende Generationen weitergegeben.
Auch eine chinesische Richtlinie von 2003
verbietet derartige Forschung.
Klar ist bislang noch nicht, ob der Forscher
vielleicht eine Sondergenehmigung für seine
Versuche bekommen hat.
Fragen wirft jedenfalls auch der Zeitpunkt
der Veröffentlichung dieser Sensationsmeldung
auf.
Denn gerade in dieser Woche kommen an der
Universität Hongkong die Pioniere des Genome
Editings zusammen und zwar beim “Second
International Summit on Human Genome Editing
(27.-29.11.18).
He Jiankui jedenfalls zeigt sich unbeeindruckt
von der Kritik und verspricht, dass seine
Daten bald veröffentlicht werden.
Er betont, dass es ihm nicht darum geht, Designerbabys
zu erschaffen.
Solche Genveränderungen sollten “ein Instrument
der Heilung” sein.
Bis die gesamten Daten seines Versuchs veröffentlicht
sind, kann nur spekuliert werden, ob tatsächlich
die ersten genveränderten Babys zur Welt
gekommen sind.
Doch schon jetzt ist eines sicher: Eine Diskussion
über diese Art der Forschung ist enorm wichtig.
Und es ist höchste Zeit, sie jetzt zu führen
- bevor es zu spät ist.
Peter Dabrock vom Deutschen Ethikrat bezeichnet
die Forschung von He Jiankui jedenfalls ganz
klar als “Menschenversuch”.
Er betont: “Die Neben- und Spätfolgen sind
noch unabsehbar und schwer zu kontrollieren.
Die Menschheit muss ein Mitspracherecht haben.
Immerhin handelt es sich um einen Eingriff
in die biologische Grundlage des Menschen."
Auf jeden Fall müssen alle beteiligten Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen jetzt sofort die
Arbeit an diesem Experiment einstellen, das
hat das chinesische Wissenschaftsministerium
jetzt bekannt gegeben.
Wir halten euch zu diesem Thema hier auf dem
Laufenden.
Wenn ihr kein Video verpassen wollt, dann
abonniert auch den englischen Kanal.
Denn auch da gibt es regelmäßig Videopremieren.
Und hier geht es direkt auf englisch weiter:
Frankenstein's heirs: Researchers create human-rat
hybrid beings Ich freue mich auf euch auf
den englischen Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned.